[Music]
what's at SLAC gmail email Apple Mail
Thunderbird telegram a lot of ways to
communicate these days and a lot of ways
to make things very very confusing but
never fear we're here to help you with
that we've distilled a framework
together from some research that we did
and we wanted to understand that yes
it's not just what you say these days
but it's how you say it
and we've come up with one very simple
rule one rule the more complex your
message the less technology you should
use more complex less technology so what
do we mean by the level of technology
well over on the right side of the
spectrum we have all of the devices that
were used to today we have mobile
devices we have apps we have email then
we have less technologically savvy
devices in the middle such as writing a
letter or even meeting in person and
then we can go all the way back to the
earliest forms of communication maybe
speaking or even smoke signals so meet
Sarah Sarah is a GSB alum she works down
the street and a new startup series B
she's got a great opportunity today she
has to give a presentation to the board
about a new pivot strategy that they
have if they go this direction it's
utter failure if they go this direction
company's gonna do great problem is she
was up late last night she didn't do the
deck she didn't finish the deck and she
slept in this morning so she's got
couple choices she has to ask someone to
help her the only person that can
actually help her finish this deck is
her boss so what does she do I chose to
attack her boss because she was already
late and it was very urgent Omega I need
to attack her
so as possible immediately now so here
are the messages she sent are you able
to read so if you were her boss can you
understand
how would you respond her same as you
guys her boss got very confused was
testing the best way to communicate this
message well it worked in some ways it
is quick in urgency and it's very
convenient you just need to grab your
phone and finish the taxing in minutes
however it did not work well because
long messages are very hard to read and
very easy to be missed
interpreted and also her boss with a
very busy schedule can be distracted by
anything else at any time and also in
some companies texting can be very
unprofessional it depends on the culture
of the company and your relationship
between you and your boss Sara could
have emailed or called her boss so if
you are going to attacks remember keep
it a simple a complex attacks will leave
them perplexed
oops huh that's not going very well for
Sara she's got a really big day thing
not only does she have this presentation
that she just might have totally screw
it up
she also has to do something else today
she has to fire the intern now it's not
just any intern
sounds easy what about if the interns
your CEOs brother's husband's nephew
there's a connection there it's gonna
make things a little bit complicated so
she has another couple of things to do
the problem with this intern is that
this intern never shows up on time and
sometimes doesn't show up at all she's
been ordered to fire the intern today
and the intern didn't show up so what'd
she do Sarah chooses to email the intern
take a look at the message put yourself
in the shoes of Michael B Arbuckle and
imagine receiving this message after
that land on you well she uses a pretty
cold and neutral subject line
termination she uses the Royal we
threw out her message she tries to
soften it by including the salutation
regretfully and a frowny-face emoticon
but that regretfully you could read that
in multiple ways depending on how the
relationship between Mike and Sarah is
maybe that's a very sincere and
heartfelt regretfully or maybe it's a
very sarcastic regretfully it's hard to
read in terms of what worked with this
email it was concise she was direct and
she structured it logically but in terms
of what didn't work this was a one-sided
message as all emails are she has no
ability to gauge the interns reaction
and to adapt accordingly and in terms of
what we said earlier and what we saw
with regretfully there are just many
ways to interpret the message like this
in fact research shows that we are much
worse at delivering tone by email than
we think in a published study scientists
had subjects deliver a message that was
either serious or sarcastic in tone and
they did this either be it via email or
phone if they did it either by email or
phone they thought that their accuracy
in delivering the intended message would
be about 80% but when they did it by
phone it was actually pretty good it was
it was 70% however with email it was
only 50 57 or 56 percent that's hardly
better than a coin flip so if I can
leave you with one takeaway here to
learn from Sarah chicken Bay tone pick
up the phone well that's two down there
was an email there was a text like I
said she has a big day today she's not
really going very very well the reason
you know when she slept in late this
morning could kind of screwed up the
whole day it set all the hours back sure
she has a job interview today not going
very well and she can't actually go to
this job interview in person she's got
to figure out what to do about that
Sarah chooses to take the job interview
over the phone this is totally normal
this is what the employer recommended
but when she hangs up she doesn't quite
know how she did she thinks it went fine
but she doesn't know whether she's gonna
get a callback or any of the feedback
that the interviewer may have had for
her so why did she do that well phone
interviews are generally accepted these
days I'm sure that we have all had a lot
of first-round phone reviews when we're
first getting to know companies it's
quick it's convenient and it's discreet
she's at work she can duck into a
conference room and take that phone
interview without her current employer
knowing that she's looking for other
jobs however there are certain things
that you can't do and that's where she
has missed those opportunities she could
have used some body language
to convey certain things that you can't
simply through your voice
it's that visual aspect of the verbal
visual and vocal framework that we've
been using similarly she may have come
off as inauthentic
people over the phone have been rated
fairly homogeneously to one another
where interviewers cannot actually
remember who they spoke to or what was
good about them now when the phone was
becoming prevalent in the US and was
starting to be used for interviews and
collecting data there were studies done
to determine whether or not this was a
good method of getting people to speak
to you what they showed were that in
terms of getting the information that
you wanted and making sure it was valid
and even conveying complex knowledge and
attitudes the phone was just as good as
doing it in person so they continued to
do so however there are a number of
situations where you may want to use an
in-person meeting such as saira had the
opportunity to and that is if you want
to do what's known as impression
management so the research on that shows
that it not only improves the rating of
likability but also allows the
individual to manage their reputation
because they're allowed to do things
like lean in to a negative feedback
rather than slink away or simply sound
defensive and scared over the phone it's
another cue that shows that you're ready
for it as opposed to scare so if you
have the opportunity and it makes sense
a face-to-face meeting may be optimal
because with face-to-face you own the
space all right we're gonna call this
the great communication breakdown 2016
for Sarah she did have one more thing to
do that day and this was actually
something exciting she'd been looking
forward to for about a month blind date
she's been set up by her friends she'd
been told all about how great this guy
was so she put on her jacket grab the
briefcase headed down the street
like a movie walked into the door light
shining down at the table at the end of
the bar um not so good she actually
knows this guy and she's not really sure
why her a friend of a friend kind of set
him up set to set them up together this
is the guy that actually puked on our
couch in college she doesn't know how
this work but she knows for sure she
does not want to go through with this
guy but she's had some communication
problems today and she thinks maybe I
should go over there and tell him in
person right wow this is a very complex
situation
so we've already told you to talk
face-to-face to deliver the complex
messages but this time Sarah chose to
text to say no she would rather to go
back home and then lay down the coach to
enjoy a bottle of very good wine gave a
happy ending to this frustrating day so
rules were meant to be broken so next
time you find yourself in a tricky
communication situation we ask you to
remember some simple rules a complex
text will leave them perplex to convey
the tone pick up the phone and we'll
face-to-face
you own the space
[Music]